you got such a big fan base people want
to hear your opinions about politics you
may want to run for president one day
and we were going back with the hora
bank and I said meant people got to know
who is what is Marc thinking about
because a lot of times CEOs don't want
to touch Paulette right they don't want
to touch it at all for whatever reason
if you were the president today Mark
Cuban is the president February 1st 2016
what are three things you're attacking
income inequality right improving the
ability for companies to raise capital
through IPOs I think that'll have a big
impact on the market you touch that on
ink you said that on the ink as well so
let's talk about income inequality
relman so how do you do that so right
now let's just say you're making thirty
five thousand dollars a year and you're
clearing fifteen hundred bucks a month
after tax and you live like a student I
don't care if you have thirty forty
fifty well sure you're living like a
student and you're able to save five
hundred bucks a month okay where you
sleep and you're staying at home you're
living at home right with your hey
two-year-old parents you're 50 years old
there's a lot of that right now yeah
unfortunately and so you're saving six
grand a month right well right now with
interest rates near zero surrounding you
or six grand a year so you're saving six
grand a year five hundred bucks a month
which is amazing that's what every
Republican wants you to do that's what
every Democrat wants you to do try to
control your own destiny now you put it
in the bank or do you put it in stocks
no one trusts the stock market no one
really knows what they're doing right no
you put it in to a fund but the problem
is if you put into a fund because you're
not making a lot of money if the
dishwasher breaks right you get
penalized for taking and show that money
out so we're in a situation right now
where it's if you put that money into
the bank which is really only the safe
way you know six thousand a year and a
year you'll have six thousand and sixty
dollars
okay sure you're just not ever going to
be as bad if that right and the point
being is you're never going to improve
your place in life right where the 1%
really the reason income has become so
unequal is I can hire anybody out
to help me pick the best investments and
I do most of it myself but I'm decent at
it right so I can put my money in stocks
I could put my and hedge against the
wrist I can put my money in whatever but
I'm liquid so I don't have to worry
about the dishwasher breaking guy if you
have six thousand dollars how are you
going to keep up right how are you going
to improve your position in life even if
you spent twenty years saving six
thousand dollars a year that's a hundred
twenty thousand dollars but you've
earned $1,500 in interest that whole
time right and while a hundred twenty
thousand is good you're not going to be
able to live off of that when you hit
sixty five or seventy years old right
not at all so part of the challenge is
how do you allow people to accumulate
capital okay without the risk of waking
up one day and not being able to get the
money out for their dishwasher or their
car or paying for their kids school
right or not um we're finding that the
stock market is way down and they're
basically wiped out and so to me that's
the first thing to address and so I
think you know one way is the Federal
Reserve I don't think you mess with the
Federal Reserve but I think you come up
with savings certificates savings bonds
that literally pay a little bit more
that allow people to save for their
future